interview répondeur
[Musique]
vous allez me laisser des messages
bonjour j'ai bien sûr porter de laurent
ruquier si vous avez un jeu de mots
laissez moi un message bip monsieur
madame tendo dans le placard parce que
tu as tu rejoues et ont une fille
comment s'appelle cette fille mélanie
pourquoi helali tendo dans le placard
parce que tu as trop chou et ouais
bonjour vous êtes bien son portable de
jamel debbouze si c'est pas pour me
demander de la thune laissez-moi message
bip
oui bonjour jamais les spas voulez vous
dire que je vous ai vu dernièrement et
j'ai envie de rejoindre votre collectif
devoir de mémoire
moi aussi j'ai changé je pense qu'il
faut régulariser les chante 1-1 à neil
harvey noir merci j'ai changé bonjour
j'ai bien sûr portable de michel sardou
si vous aussi vous êtes pour laissez moi
un message bip pour on serait pour nous
l'ouverture des magasins le dimanche
oui il devrait faire une chanson là
dessus plutôt d'accord bonjour j'ai bien
sûr le portable de claude berri si vous
voulez pitch est un film laissez moi un
message bip
je pense qu'il n'appellera pas bonjour
vous êtes bien sur portable de jacques
et bernadette chirac
si vous avez des pièces jaunes laissez
moi un message beef bonjour
jacques chirac c'est gérald un amer
donnant limitée zidane là bonjour vous
êtes bien sur portable de nicolas
sarkozy si c'est pour revenir à la
maison laissez nous un message
ouais nicolas nicolas
alors ouais c'est professeur ousmane
donc là j'ai fait revenir les primes et
donc il faut faire revenir mon appart la
cité p
bonjour j'ai bien sûr le portable de
florent pagny si c'est pour un conseil
fiscal laissez-moi message bip
oui bonjour florent c'est johnny
hallyday dit donc au lieu d'aller en
patagonie tu aurais dû aller en belgique
c'est plus près bonjour je viens son
portable de gérard depardieu je suis
bourré c'est moi un message bip
oui elle ou hockey géreur si gérald en
mer de nouvelle crise
ah bonjour j'ai bien son portable de
dieudonné
si c'est pour la vérité si je mens 3
laissez moi un message mais là mon avis
il faut pas les encoder parce qu'on est
sur écoute the do with you know dont là
on est donc voila tout pour te dire que
le loup est dans la bergerie
bonjour j'ai bien son portable de george
bush je sais c'est incroyable mais
laissez moi un message bip
oui c'est incroyable parce que je
t'appelle de ma tombe c'est martin
luther king j'ai grandi avec moi et
quand tu vas venir dans l'au-delà nous
on a arrêté les actions non violentes
on va défoncer la gueule bonjour vous
êtes bien son portable de omar et fred
en est chez ardisson laissez nous un
message bip
oui il bonjour je vous appelle pour
savoir où on peut réserver des places
pour les valeurs spectacle on n'a pas
donné l'adresse ni les points de vente
habituels il me semble parce que ma
cousine m'a dit que c'était à la grande
comédie rue de clichy laquelle heures à
20 heures
dès mardi au samedi oui je crois et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce
bleu